DANA?
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> UNFORTUNATELY THIS SIMPLE
LIFE-SAVING PRACTICE HAS BECOME
PART OF THE POLITICAL DEBATE
THAT SAYS THIS, IF YOU’RE FOR
TRUMP YOU DON’T WEAR A MASK AND
IF YOU’RE AGAINST HIM YOU DO.
THAT’S WHY I’VE SUGGESTED TO THE
PRESIDENT OCCASIONALLY WEAR A
MASK.
EVEN THOUGH IN MOST CASES IT’S
NOT NECESSARY FOR HIM TO DO SO.
>> Dana: IT’S
SENATOR LAMAR ALEXANDER SAYING
THE DEBATE ON WEARING A MASK IS
TURNING POLITICAL, BUT IS IT
EVEN LEGAL TO MAKE IT MANDATORY?
21 STATES AND THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA REQUIRE MASKS FOR
PEOPLE AND/OR ADD IN PUBLIC
SPACES.
LET’S GET SOME INSIGHT FROM A
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY BRENT
TOLMAN.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
WE DON’T HAVE YOUR EXCELLENT
CITY BACKGROUND, YOUR ROOM LOOKS
GREAT AS WELL.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WONDERING THIS, BUT WE TRY TO BE
RESPECTFUL, WE WANT TO DO WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS WE NEED TO
DO TO FLATTEN A CURVE AND NOT
OVERWHELM THE HOSPITAL.
UNDER LEGAL AUTHORITY IS THE
GOVERNMENT ALLOWED TO DO THAT TO
US?
>> YOUR STATE AND CITY
GOVERNMENTS DO HAVE THE ABILITY
DURING AN EMERGENCY TO ISSUE
RULINGS IN ESSENCE, ORDERS THAT
ARE TEMPORARY.
AND THERE MEANT TO STAVE OFF
SOME EXISTING EMERGENCY.
THE PROBLEM WE REALLY HAVE HERE
IS WHERE GETTING AND CONSISTENT
MESSAGES AND INCONSISTENT
TREATMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EVERYBODY IS NOTICING IT.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I BROUGHT UP YESTERDAY WAS
WHEN YOU HAVE A MANDATORY
EVACUATION AND A HURRICANE AREA,
THE GOVERNMENT CAN’T MAKE YOU
GO.
IS A MASK, A MANDATORY MASK
WEARING MANDATE SIMILAR?
>> GREAT ANALOGY AND WHAT’S
GOING TO BE INTERESTING IS THEY
CAN MAKE THAT RULE, THEY CAN
ISSUE THAT ORDER.
THEIR WAY TO ENFORCE IT IS
THROUGH THE USE OF POLICE POWER
WHICH THE STATE HAS AND THEY’RE
THE ONLY ONES THAT CAN EXERCISE
THE POLICE POWER IN THAT REGARD.
ARE WE GOING TO DO THAT?
ARE WE GOING TO SEE ARRESTS?
INTERESTING AND UNBELIEVABLE
TIME THAT THAT MAY BE HAPPENING
RIGHT AS SOME OF THE SAME CITIES
ARE CALLING AND SCREAMING FOR
DEFUNDING OF THE POLICE.
>> Dana: AND DEED OF THE OTHER
THING IS I THINK YOU SEE
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
DESPERATE TO GET BACK OPEN.
THIS IS THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND HOW
THEY SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES,
BUT THEY DON’T HAVE ANY BACKUP.
THEY’RE THE ONES HAVING TO
ENFORCE THE MASK WEARING IN
THEIR STORES BECAUSE THE POLICE
DON’T HAVE TIME.
OR RESOURCES TO GO AROUND AND DO
IT FOR THEM.
LAST WORD.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT AND IT’S
REALLY HARD WHEN WE SEE AREAS
THAT ARE STIFF AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND SPACING SEEMS
TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE THERE AS
OPPOSED TO SOME OF OUR LARGER
CITIES.
THE THING THAT IS REALLY
DIFFICULT AS THE COUNTRY WATCHES
THEM AND SEIZE THE MORTALITY
RATE GOING DOWN, AND THE
POSITIVE TEST GOING UP.
THEY’RE CONFUSED IF IT’S AN
EMERGENCY OR A REGULAR FLU THAT